note toujours les mêmes contradictions
entre ce que vous nous dites et vous
répéter les éléments de langage que nous
avions déjà entendus dont contradiction
avec les déclarations des syndicats de
police que vous avez jugé fantaisiste
mais aussi avec les déclarations de
monsieur benalla lui même parce que
monsieur benalla lui même à tf1 le 27
juillet ne consteste et nullement
s'occuper d'eux notamment d'art
organisation du service de protection en
disant même qu'il avait le ministère de
l'intérieur contre lui vous nous dites
aussi comme d'autres qu'il n'avait aucun
problème relationnel avec personne or il
nous dit exactement contraire puisque il
dit il dit même qu'il était considéré
comme comme un extraterrestre
je suis l'extra terrestre de la bande et
ça fait chier beaucoup de gens nous dit
il bon alors c'est étonnant parce que
personne n'a remarqué est ce qu'il est
complètement paranoïaque pour avoir ce
type de sentiments estime de déclaration
pour que personne veut dire à l'elysée
et pu le remarquer alors c'est vous même
qui dit l'avoir recruté le directeur de
cabinet nous avait dit que c'était lui
d'habitude on soit filet pas tas de
choses à vous la revendiquer tous les
deux dans son cv
ces voix et ses références étaient
exclusivement liés à la sécurité n'y a
pas que bethio octobre il ya tout tout
aisée et aucune autre acteur
l'ordre est savoir sur quels critères
strictement vous avez décidé sur foot
mans parce que la question vous a été
posée je crois que vous n'avez vous avez
un père fait mme en eux
oui mais la question il pose une
dernière question son traitement serait
de 6000 euros
nous à nous at on appris s'est vu hier
soir à la télé que c'était autant que
directeur de mediapart est un peu plus
qu'un parlementaire mais ma question
c'est est-ce que sa rémunération se
limite strictement à cela est ce que il
n'ya pas des primes ou d'autres
rémunérations qui n'apparaissent pas sur
les fiches de paye et qui sur autres
voilà